é bom dia a todos obrigado pelo convite
é eu vou fazer meu trabalho atualmente
no parque nacional iguaçu chefe do
parque sou servidor vou fazer conta uma
historinha aqui para vocês espero que
essa história que a história da minha
vida convenção ou não convença vocês
sobre a importância de participar
nacionais
[Música]
eu sou criado e nasci e me criei em
chapecó santa catarina não é santa
catarina onde eu tive meus pais adoravam
acampado desde cedo praticamente aquela
nasci em acampamento nasce vivenciando
experimentando natureza selvagem e
natureza em sua plenitude
a região do oeste santa catarina
principalmente ao longo do rio uruguai a
uma das regiões belíssimas net uma
qualidade ambiental não só de beleza
cênica mais de rios de natureza selvagem
de vida selvagem como é atualmente o
como é o parque nacional do iguaçu rio
uruguai a gente acampada chegou a passar
meses no rio uruguai acampando e
desfrutando desse tipo de nessa
qualidade de vida e nessas andanças de
mel com meus pais na campanha
nós vemos a foz do iguaçu viemos
conhecer parque nacional do iguaçu e
acampamos antigamente se acampar vale
onde o restaurante porto canoas já
acampavam naquele local
nós acampamos na que exatamente onde é o
estacionamento e de todas as
experiências que a gente teve no parque
nacional assuma mudou minha vida
transformou minha vida e me fez o que eu
sou hoje acreditar no que estou falando
para vocês eu fui eu adorava pescar e
querendo ganhar do uruguai adorava
pescar e ali naquele local cheio de
peixes eu não existia eu vi um monte de
peixes e fui peguei-me alinhada e fui
pescar e não deu outra eu fui flagrado
pela guarda parque fui surpreendido por
um agente um servidor público é federal
que estava fazendo a fiscalização
cuidando do parque e eu ali pescando eu
era um menino de 10 anos e esse esse
servidor público e cidadão essa pessoa
ele não disse a palavra não ele veio me
deu uma aula de parques nacionais
ele explicou que que é um parque
nacional para que serve para anos e
aquino um menino de dez anos aquilo
marcou a minha vida aquilo foi tipo
assim pegou na veia tocou meu coração as
palavras dele o que ele falou de parque
nacional aquilo passou a ser meu sonho e
ele passou a ser minha referência eu
passei a pensar em ser como aquele
servidor aquele guarda parque eu tinha
10 anos
aí segue se a vida voltei para chapecó
gente ficar jovem faz vai pra tudo
quanto é lugar faz festa e 77
até que no final da década de 90
meus pais mudam para mato grosso nesse
ínterim que eu estava a exercitando
ainda pensando em ser guarda parque
ocupa alimentando o meu sonho as
florestas e os rios da região oeste não
só da região oeste de santa catarina mas
na região oeste sudoeste do paraná áreas
foram transformados a gente produzir
nosso alimento presente produzir pra
gente crescer e se desenvolver
isso aconteceu e tudo aquilo que eu
vivenciei na minha infância de repente
se socorreu ea gente perdeu aquele
aquela coisa toda mas no final da 10 70
gente muda meu pai com uma leva de
sulistas vão para mato grosso é buscar a
vida e nós vamos juntos eu vou junto nós
vamos encerrar duet eu tenho uma
experiência né de jovem de vivenciar os
grandes cerrados brasileiros aquela
plenitude do cerrado brasileiro uma
imensidão interminável né de cerrado com
biodiversidade com o quixadá conta com
onça com sucuri enfim mas meu pai estava
lá trabalhando com compra e venda de
fazendas ele comprava fazenda e nem
gostava dividir e vendia suas pequenas
propriedades ele estava também neste
processo e eu estava fazendo parte desse
processo mas me encantava fazia parte da
minha vida contato com a natureza
experiência vivência com a natureza e
com fome a gente é o meu pai é dividindo
as propriedades da hora ou outra parece
uma propriedade que nos interessava mas
quanto eu me apaixonava por que eu
queria ter estava dentro de mim ser uma
pessoa tava lá em contato com a natureza
quando me encantava com a propriedade me
apaixonava com essa propriedade no pai
vendia porque o sonho dele era outro o
pai meu pai tinha um sonho que os filhos
tinham que ter diploma universitário
tinha passar por vez
cidades o último filho o mais novo e ele
acreditava nisso e eu estava vivendo a
maior experiência da minha vida que eu
mais gostava que a viver em contato com
a natureza mesmo sendo uma fazenda em
fim dos sonhos diferentes nós acabamos
conflitando esse conflito uma hora foi
denso e uma discussão acalorada você é o
homem feito imagina homem feito com 19
anos né
já é que peguei discutir com o meu pai
vergonha foi com o quadro está fazendo
minha mochila para e possuo voltar para
o sul para a casa de um irmão me abrigar
na casa me protegendo a casa de alguns
de meus irmãos e minha mãe
essa possibilidade essa essa leveza que
as que é uma é uma benção das mulheres é
uma carteira das mulheres é um tributo
das mulheres ela lembrou de meu sonho
ela resgatou meu sonho de dez anos
aprendido aqui na no parque nacional do
iguaçu e descobriu que em cuiabá via um
curso chamado engenharia florestal não
sabia nem o que era isso que a
engenheira florestal nem ela sabia mas
de repente ela me convenceu de que isso
poderia ser aquilo que eu queria ser
quando criança que ela seja
guarda-parque trabalhar com conservação
talvez engenharia florestal
bem eu estava com a mochila pronta netta
plano com a parte em vez de possuo
funorte foi para cuiabá
estudei gente estudei muito com a morte
e vocês estão aqui estudando isto disso
de ecologistas de conservação e me
dediquei a conservação da natureza
profundamente estudei muito pantanal
estudei muito rio cuiabá e estudei muito
chapada dos guimarães chapada dos
guimarães fica ali do lado de cuiabá ea
mesmo o mesmo processo que eu vi na
minha infância na região oeste de santa
catarina que eu acompanhei na minha
juventude na rede nos cerrados do brasil
estava acontecendo na chapada dos
guimarães na no sopé e na porta da
chapada chegando o processo de
transformação transformando o cerrado só
uma das paisagens a especulação
imobiliária e ambientes como esse
estariam perdidos porque sabe um cheio
de casas e dentro 'pista e no cerne da
universidade cd surge um núcleo
discutindo conservação da natureza esse
núcleo professor optou por
nossa de criação do parque nacional
chapada dos guimarães que se tornou o
fato na sequência nós criamos o parque
nacional da chapada dos guimarães
enfim me formei fui para amazônia fiquei
lá uns três meses vivenciando a grande
floresta amazônica fantástica
maravilhosa
bill diversa e de repente me chamaram me
provocar um para trabalhar em mato
grosso do sul voltar onde meus pais
estavam o estado de mato grosso tinha
recém sido criado estava estabelecendo
seus institutos e meio ambiente e seus
órgãos ambientais e foi provocado para
disputar uma uma concurso uma seleção e
me dei bem
fui lá na entrevista passei fui
selecionado e talvez um prêmio pra mim
foi um prémio mas eu fui destacado para
estava lá em bonito mato grosso do sul
cuidar da agenda ambiental de macaé
bonito junto à serra da bodoquena uma
região de relevo cárstico nós já conhece
lá de cavernas rios subterrâneos água
cristalina uma floresta decidual
fantástica pelo mais vida selvagem
fantástica e passando pelo mesmo
processo que todas as outras áreas
estavam passando a gente perdendo
recursos perder natureza transformando
memória de uma nação transformando as
paisagens
desculpe que reflete a memória da nossa
nação t sendo transformada aí já
profissional com qualidade resgatamos um
projeto de parque nacional e criamos foi
criado em 2001 criado parque nacional da
serra da bodoquena que salvaguarda
protege que garante essa memória essa
feição essa beleza da aaa da nossa nação
brasileira da região de bonito que
bonito é pouco para aquela região tem
conhece sabe
enfim conseguimos garantir isso mas
talvez uma inquietude ainda meus eu
sempre fui um ser muito inquieto não é
um é tá faltando alguma coisa aí surgiu
em 2002 um concurso do ibama para
analista ambiental eu nunca tinha
pensado na vida e fazer concurso
eu estava muito bem lá em bonito
trabalhando a mas uns colegas falam têm
tudo a ver contigo a sua cara
você tem tudo a ver com o servidor
público federal e trabalha no impactos
reserva
enfim lá eu faço faço o concurso do
ibama e acerta na mosca né é assim bôla
de och de mato grosso nós passamos em
cinco do que aquela prova que eu fiz
tudo o que tinha visto na vida estava
ali aquilo era materialização da minha
experiência de vida entre o ibama em
2002 a eles que se passa isso é da serra
da bodoquena também tinha isso abrir já
que é o símbolo paraná que está aqui não
tem mais lá existe então foi protegida
com isso mas enfim entrou no ibama vou
dar uma rodada pelo pelo ceará e me
convidam para trabalhar no estado de
mato grosso do sul
desculpe me convidam para vínculos esse
perdão eu estou com problema na garganta
mas me convidam
o presidente do ibama me convida para um
desafio e vir trabalhar no parque
nacional do iguaçu que estava passando
no momento que precisava de ajuda
imediatamente aceito porque eu sou de
chapecó estou aqui da região agora sou
foz do iguaçu em si mas a mesma floresta
vinha de chapecó até que na minha
infância uma onça pois não poderia
circular um grande carnívoro floresta
uma só elas circulavam em chapecó até
aqui pelos corredores gustavo tatá e
sobraram somente ilhas
enfim 2003 vim pra cá tem 16 anos que me
dedico a conservação me dedico a a a
contribuir à conservação de parque
nacional do iguaçu que já foi falado
aqui com algumas pessoas mas que abriga
protege salvaguarda uma das feições mais
impressionantes do equipamento planeta e
uma das eleições que é nosso sim das
feições que representa a nossa nação e
isso é papel do parque nacional o papel
do parque nacional é garantir a memória
de um país garante memória uma nação por
isso é uma parte nacional e ao mesmo
tempo também garantir que a vida
selvagem exista garantir que as espécies
que a gente perdeu em chapecó
a gente perdeu um cerrado que perdeu
alguns galhos que as espécies existentes
e para isso a gente tem que ser
guerreiro tem que ser agressivo tem que
ser forte porque assim as pressões são
muito grandes para que a gente perca
esse recurso e ao longo da nossa
história muito perdendo perdendo
perdendo
felizmente há 80 anos atrás nós
completamos hoje 80 anos foi criado o
parque nacional do iguaçu que protege
uma natureza esplende natureza divina
uma vida selvagem que poucos lugares
país tem a maior representatividade à
memória das florestas da mata atlântica
do interior está guardada no parque
nacional do iguaçu estão muito além da
importância de cataratas do iguaçu o
parque nacional do iguaçu protege a vida
selvagem protege a natureza selvagem
há dez anos atrás para finalizar há dez
anos atrás a gente está 11 pintado é
nosso símbolo ela está na nossa logo ela
é nossa referência o caminho mais
poderoso das américas é fantástico
maravilhoso há dez anos atrás nós
estávamos perdendo essa espécie aqui ela
estaria extinta
se nós não tomássemos medidas muito
enérgicas muito decisivo muito positivas
para voltar a tentar salvar e hoje nós
estamos salvando a população em dez anos
mais que dobrou e é uma relação à
internacional de fronteira brasil
argentina
nós vamos conseguir um trabalho conjunto
fazer com que essa espécie que essa
espécie continue a viver em nossas
florestas continuam a fazer parte da
nossa vida é eu tenho um filmezinho que
eu gostaria de passar por favor é um
vídeo não sei se eu tenho que tocar aqui
mas que representa muito bem essa aí
pode passar algumas vezes eu acho que eu
tenho o meu tempo tá quase esgotando mas
para finalizar é como resultado é de
todo um trabalho todo uma dedicação do
entendimento que é porque a gente cria
parques essa idéia de falar para vocês
porque nós criamos ao longo da nossa
história parques nacionais e por que nós
protegemos parte nacionais porque a
gente protege realmente a memória da
nação a gente protege a vida a expressão
do que existe numa nas nações na nossa
nação brasileira e não só de beleza
cênica não só de chapada não só de
catarata
mas salvaguarda protege e garante de
existência todos os nossos pés como
harpia harpyja que está na nossa logo
desapareceu do estado mas ainda é
possível a gente salvar uma população de
onça pintada e essa onça que vocês vêm
aí ela chama atiaia essa onça é uma
fêmea que está há cinco anos sendo
acompanhado por nós é a segunda cria
dela e ela nos brindou com três filhotes
há um ano eles estão completando agora
em abril três anos a gente tem
acompanhado
ontem à noite houve um dos filhotes a
gente tem acompanhado então um esforço
de várias pessoas o esforço dos
servidores públicos e um esforço uma
decisão de fazer a gente consegue salvar
vida selvagem ao mesmo tempo no lugar
que recebe dois milhões de visitantes
área de vida da atiaia é do portão do
parque até as cataratas onde elas
circula com três filhotes de onde
circulam mais de dois milhões de
visitantes em torno de 2 milhões de
visitantes brigado